[Music]
welcome
my name is will torres this is
application week connecting the dots
each day this week we've been focusing
on different pieces of the application
and so um we navigated through what are
the different parts
uh we talked about testing transcripts
academics
yesterday we talked a lot about letters
of recommendation and reference
tips for both folks applying as well as
recommenders
today we're going to put those dots
together and i'm
really excited about this because one of
the things that
i learned over my career as an
admissions professional
is that no single part of the
application
like you know they all belong together
together they're the things that help us
really understand who you are
so it's not about the dots specifically
but what is that picture what
is that constellation if you think about
those dots of stars
right each one of those sections is an
area for you to shine
what is the constellation that is drawn
when we step back
and look at all of those pieces together
and so
i'm joined today we are going to start
with panelist introductions i'm so
excited i don't really get to do a lot
of panels with stephanie so
you can tell where my energy is we'll
talk about the holistic review process
then we'll have we'll start with a
moderated q a and then we'll turn to the
q
a box we'll be infusing your questions
all the way through
so if you see questions that you are
particularly inspired by
or that resonate with you go ahead and
click that thumbs up button
that will upvote that question and help
it uh get to the top of the list
all right so with that um stephanie
yes it's been a brief introduction and
what is
one of your life goals
putting me on the spot well welcome
everybody my name
is stephanie whitlen i am one of the
admissions officers at the stanford
graduate school of business
and i'm delighted today to join will in
this session
well i love how you described it as a
constellation i
i made note of that because it very much
does describe
how each element is intertwined and how
together
it creates something so i love that um
one of my life goals well i have a son
now um he's eight so i've had him for a
few years but
um i think for me the most
i've always been a curious person and
someone
who seeks to understand and
my life goal is to make sure that
he and myself are able to explore
and learn more about the world and i
think that's really important from
a perspective of a child growing up and
exploring and um being curious and being
aware
and being open-minded so okay my heart
just
kind of exploded for a little bit that
is
such a heartfelt and authentic response
to that answer and it just
kind of yes i am feeling that i'm here
to support you
all the way through and so as we go
through like think about your dreams
think about your life goals for
everybody out there
think about like dream big and how can
business school
help you reach those dreams and i think
that's one of those things that i like
to encourage folks to think about
your career infuses so much of who you
are
so it's things about curiosity you know
who are the people in your life it might
be your son
right and how are you going to live a
meaningful
constructive life that when you look
back on you can be proud of
and so if business school is part of
that path we are here to help guide you
along it
and so just to set a little bit of a
foundation about what we're gonna cover
it's gonna be
both at that high level and we'll go
ahead and dig into the little bits too
so at the gsb we're looking for things
in three general buckets
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential
and personal qualities and contributions
these are background agnostic
meaning that we find them anywhere in
your life
from all different walks of life any
career
kind of school background there are so
many ways to show
these three qualities and different
types of qualities within them
and we celebrate and recognize wherever
they come up for you
they're also context dependent so we
know if you are
earlier in your career versus later
there's going to be a different set of
opportunities
and that's normal and we're taking that
into account as we're reading your
application
your application consists of a bunch of
different sections these stars that i
referred to earlier
and it's through these that we get that
picture of who you are
yes it's an imperfect picture because
you are so much more
than what's going to be contained on
those pages but
through this application we're trying to
understand who you are
how you're going to show up in our
classrooms and in our community
so with that i'm going to stop sharing
and then stephanie we are going to spend
a good amount of time just talking about
the application so from your
from where you sit what does a strong
application look like
well there is no one formula first
but for what strong looks like and
certainly for us who are evaluating
candidates
we are taking a holistic approach which
is why this is
a great session on connecting the dots
it's being able to see
evidence throughout the application
where there's
parts that sort of sparkle or show up in
terms of
someone's impact that they've had or the
ways in which they've been
intellectually engaged um
so it's it's it's not um a specific
thing and i think that's what makes it
so hard to explain
um but we certainly more than anything
are looking to learn about you so strong
applications are those
people or those candidates who can
really convey
who they are as a person and what
they've done
in a you know concise way
uh and use all parts of the application
to demonstrate those qualities yeah i
i love you mentioned evidence at the
beginning and i think that's one of
those pieces that
if you think about that analogy of that
picture that i just showed earlier where
each part of the application was a
different
part of a greater picture um
it's those evidence pieces that really
adds clarity and definition
to those sections and helps us
understand okay this is how
this piece is together um would you say
that like
kind of resonates does that sound yeah
actually i'll use an example because i
think
people are so um focused on
they see one of our criteria is
intellectual vitality and you may
initially drive to oh that means they're
looking at my gmat and my
gre or gpas so all of that so whether it
was a test score or gpa
and while that certainly is part of
intellectual vitality
uh as someone who's evaluating
applications i'm looking for it all over
the place and
and a great example is like it could
it could come up in a letter of
recommendation where the recommender is
indicating that
this particular individual saw a need to
develop a new tool that would help
improve
um a system or project and
as a result they then um taught others
but they
learned it on their own and then they
applied it to what they were doing and
if that isn't intellectual vitality i
don't know what is so it's like
you're looking for places where you see
someone who's just
intellectually curious who is engaged
they have a willingness to
learn they want to share them with
others
and i think it is so much more than just
a gpa or a test score and so
i want people to really understand that
as we read that
i see that and i'm like wow that that's
strong evidence
of someone's intellectual identity they
took something above and beyond
and then they they grew it and being
able to really see that
curiosity come through um is fascinating
so yeah look so all of these things
could come up in different ways
are there any unexpected places
as well you gave one example um for us
to think broadly about where things
could come up i know
sometimes kind of staying on the theme
of intellectual vitality
i've seen it come up in the background
question where we're asking about
a time in the last few years where your
background has influenced your
participation in something
um and sometimes even the way folks
engage with
who they are that level of
self-awareness and connection to the
world around them
there is a level of intellectual
vitality there as well like there's so
many types of intellect like
um emotional intelligence
people intelligence tactical sometimes
people are like
really good in like visualizing things
so i think there's so many different
ways to show even different types of
intelligence yeah and so just lean into
the things that feel natural and
resonate for you
yeah that's my thing yeah
i mean overarching to while we've
already kind of addressed the question
astronomic application is just really
going to convey
who you are right and so to the extent
that you can do that
you're you're putting your best foot
forward so
we want to see all elements of you as a
person
yeah so your perfect segue and folks in
the q and a box are already beating me
so that's the next question that i was
good i wanted us to
to unpack a little bit so we i've been
using the analogy of here's a bigger
picture
and the application shows different
parts we can use the example of a
constellation with different stars and
so there's
also a number of questions about do
these have to connect
um you know do i have to make sure
things
resonate across or can things be stand
alone
um what let's let's let's go there let's
talk about
how do we think about the sections in
concert with each other because even the
theme of today's
q a this panel is like connecting the
dots so right
any thoughts that you have let's let's
go let's go there um
i i don't think it needs to be as as
perfectly woven together as you think it
may
there might be elements of your life
that are an important piece of who you
are but don't necessarily show up in
other places
um i think there certainly wants to be i
want to see a theme of
what's important to you um what you
value
and i imagine that those are going to
show up in different ways throughout the
application
um trying to think if there's anything
else i can
sort of convey as it relates to um
describing so for example you you said
before how
there might be something in the
background in perspective that gives us
some idea
about um how the life they've lived
and the experiences they've had have um
impacted the way that they view the
world or even how they present
in the workplace and we might see some
small evidence of that and then also
notice that a recommender or in your
lors or even in your essays that you
elaborate more
on that and then that becomes another
piece of who you are
and we get to see that elsewhere but i
don't think we're necessarily
looking to make that to tie a bow
um i think everyone is so multi-faceted
taking all the components and then
building the picture
of who you are and you may be a
different person in different contexts
and bring different things to different
communities that you're involved with
yeah sorry my eyes just lit up as you
were talking about how you might live in
different communities
be a different individual knowing that
for many folks
there might be some element of code
switching where maybe the language or
the presence
you know you might show up differently
at work than you do at home but that
doesn't mean
that's still you right those are still
elements and manifestations of who you
are
so even if and i've learned this over
time too it's like
even if things might seem like
disjointed you as an individual because
you're the one going through them
they are connected and so i wouldn't um
have anybody out there feel worried that
things don't always seem like as you
said tied into a perfect bow
but really as you dig deeper and think
about okay you as an individual like as
you center yourself
you are the connector so what is it
about you that's bringing those things
together because
at some level yeah they're going to be
connected
through you so i think that's yeah
i think being able to to look at
yourself as
more than the one-dimensional paper
screen that you're
um i think uh we all are aware that
individuals
human beings are complex and so
there's so many different um facets that
we're going to learn about and i think
that what that's what makes our
application so robust and that we give
candidates the opportunity to
demonstrate all of those
in many different places on the
application
all right so where there is a question
in the q a box destiny
it has three times the number of up
votes as everybody okay as any other
question
so let's go there because also i i'm
a big fan of starting with here's things
to watch out for
and then here's how to address them so
maybe if we can start with
like what were in any examples that
we've seen of definite like quote
unquote not to do's
or as i like to think of them areas of
opportunity
and then you know afterwards we can talk
about like
all right now let's how to beef things
like that up so
any red flags for you i mean the
most obvious um not to do or definite
not to do
is to not answer the questions that we
ask of you right
like we literally do want you to take
the time
and answer the prompts that we have
provided for you
there's reason and meaning behind what
we ask
and so we're trying to capture that
information
um i mean add an overarching just
you know following instructions um and
and really putting your best foot
forward and really answering
the prompts as they're provided yeah
there's been times i read
essays and and i'd finish i'm like i
actually don't know what matters to you
and so that
i i think that's like for me the epitome
of what you were saying right now
um there's this other level of that too
not just that
question and prompt itself but as you
look at the application
like every blank spots and opportunity
optional yes that isn't you
that doesn't mean you have to use it but
when we're asking you
in your employment or work history
section um
information about those roles sometimes
i i see people leave those blank
and then the application itself looks
very sparse
and there's not enough meat in the
resume to help
cover that so as you're thinking about
both like every element
as you know a different angle on who you
are i think that's one of those
not complete like red flags but
something for you to think about
as you're you're doing this like um just
that
completeness and an effort element i'm
first you brought that
up you know i do we um
ask folks to submit a resume but there's
also the employment section and we ask
people to fill that out
and um it is
if you see what i would say is a thinner
application where some of those places
are not filled out
it does beg the question of the amount
of effort you put into it
um because certainly while we can see
what you've done on your resume we
provide those other
places on the application for you to
really
articulate things more clearly and it's
helpful to us
we don't ask it just to fill the space
we genuinely have
a desire and understanding and so
um be sure that you are putting your
best foot forward
and and not giving us any instance where
we have to think
hmm what kind of effort or commitment
that they have to this process
yeah outside of the optional questions
because those are optional like truly
truly true
yes of course right we've included
people who have filled all of them out
we've admitted people who have
left them all blank so know that truly
obviously
and i think that's one of the questions
that comes up it probably i thought that
might be the top line question would
have to answer so yes let me
first please reiterate that if we say it
is
optional it is genuinely optional um and
we only want you to include something if
you feel like it's compelling that it
provides
you with another opportunity to share
something that you may not have been
able to communicate elsewhere
in the application but we absolutely do
not look or
put anyone at a disadvantage if for
example
do not fill out the optional impact
questions or those short answers
so i could not have planted a better
segway for
the next stop question here we're
talking a lot about connecting the dots
here's some optional spaces so and
and i think this like works perfectly
with today's topic um
so this is a question from advan how do
you see successful applicants use the
optional essays do they answer all of
them present
um to provide as many pieces as possible
or answer fewer to better highlight the
important aspects like
when might be a time to
to use those impact questions any let's
let's shed some light there yeah there's
so many ways that they can be used and
i've seen it done
in many ways and there's no one right
way to do it
and oftentimes the impact prompts can be
a great opportunity for you
to elaborate on a particular
extracurricular
or activity or community organization
you are a part of and to talk a little
bit about
maybe the impact you had and again i
want people to understand
that the impact doesn't have to be
at a large scale it can also be the
impact you've had
with a mentee or as you were
tutoring or coaching one individual and
helped support that person
as they were navigating their either
educational journey
or even career journey so um
i see the impact essays as a nice way to
elaborate on some of the things you have
done and maybe have
um glo not glossed over but weren't able
to elaborate as much on elsewhere in the
application
it's also nice to see you know there
might be something
on your resume that you've indicated
that you're really
proud of because it was a a big success
or accomplishment
and then to be able to take one piece or
component of that and really give us
a little bit more meat so it's all about
getting um evidence so you know we are
evidence-based in terms of how we
evaluate we want to see what you've done
and i do believe that the impact prompts
give
us that opportunity to step a little bit
smaller
they're like snippets you know it's not
something that you necessarily
need to incorporate into an essay but
they can be small vignettes of ways in
which
and most impactful i'm i'm about to
start using small vignettes that's
just i love that um yeah cause like
you're saying
your resume says what right often
oftentimes that's how the a resume is
structured
like this is what i did this is what i
did but
that often misses we don't have enough
space to talk about the how
right if you're thinking about some of
those leadership competencies
how did you get that thing to happen
what was the ripple effect or
why was it significant for that you know
person or organization or place
and sometimes that that next step of
helping us
understand like what did your footprint
look like it's
you know you don't necessarily have that
same space in the resume um i would also
say sometimes
in the um essays right sometimes you
might refer to something
yeah but um stephanie
do you remember workshop being the
wording for these optional questions
just like how precise we were trying to
be to make sure it was clear
um i think for the folks out there even
letting you know what the
historical like how these questions were
born might be helpful and um
how to understand them so in the past
so we've had the what matters most to
you and why essay for a really long time
um and over time we're finding that
people were trying to put um
a call accomplishments they were
stuffing accomplishments yeah
and it's definitely worth being proud of
and we definitely want to learn about
them
but it didn't right it didn't always fit
with the flow of what they were
talking about as mattering or it made
essays seem like here's what matters and
here's evidence
versus yes yeah yeah i mean let me
explain why
and while it is important for you to
explain why something matters it doesn't
need to be like i did x
y and z and that's why so that's where
the
um the genesis of these optional
questions came into play
this allows you to both answer kind of
to the fullest and however you want in
any of those other spaces
and then still have dedicated space to
elab that give us those
kind of how why what of the
accomplishments you've had
um and that's why there's three as well
like they don't always have to be
connected
sometimes accomplishments come in many
different parts of your life
there doesn't even have to be a
reference to them anywhere else in the
application um each of those can be
standalone
or they can be used to um kind of give
more depth somewhere else
um so that is a very long-winded way of
saying use it in a way that feels right
for you
yeah and i like i i think it is
important to reiterate
that what we genuinely are looking for
and the what matters most and why is to
find out
who you are as a person and what is
meaningful for you
and we want you to go deep in a way that
allows you to share
those reasons uh and we want you to take
maybe some of this other stuff which you
may have put in there because you felt
like you still
wanted to share those stories which we
value as well
but now you have another space to put
those and so that's the intent
of the impact essay or the impact short
answers
and i would say that um as will shared
like they don't have to
be intertwined they can be three
disparate
and that's probably typical i would even
say
um don't try to fill this space if you
don't genuinely have
something significant to share you may
have already conveyed what you needed to
you can do too strong you could have one
strong one that really
speaks to a way in which you've been
impactful
so we don't want you to water down by
also trying to just
give us all three if you feel that
you can share um impact
more succinctly in one or two so
oh i'm loving this i'm loving these
questions in the q and a box so we're
already like
we're deviating from our experience it's
way more fun this is way more fun
um so sure is asking about how do we
convey intellectual vitality and
leadership
in what matters most there's going to be
some myth busting here and i think
that's why this one made me light up
alums have said this essay must be from
heartfelt
must be from somewhere heartfelt and
vulnerable i wonder how to talk about
intellect and leadership here i think
this is such a fascinating question
because you're understanding both hey
what are the things that the gsb is
looking for
how can i be thoughtful about what i'm
writing
and like how do i balance like like all
of
the advice and different things that i'm
hearing and and of course that myth
busting element
so um stephanie can let's talk a little
bit about the essays right um
how do they fit in with the greater
picture of the application what makes
a quote-unquote well let's say let's say
helpful
essay as opposed to a good or bad
because even shifting our mind frame
about how we use the essays might help
people
uh feel more comfortable with what
they're writing um
and then let's unpack this like the
necessity of it being um
heartfelt and vulnerable like that has a
lot
that has a lot yeah that's that's deep
um we want you to be um introspective we
want to hear your authentic voice
so these those things are important um
the best way to describe the
essay and how it can most
effectively convey who you are is to
have someone who knows you
really really well read your essay and
make sure it sounds like
you and authentically you i don't know
that necessarily has to be vulnerable
you do not have to
you know we do those talk sessions and
if there's anything i've learned
from the talk um and for those of you on
the line if you're unaware
um this is a really sort of a gsb
tradition of students sharing
a story with their classmates that might
also be very heartfelt and vulnerable
that's where you're starting to see
those elements come in
and um i have heard them say
in the coaching of that that we
you can share as much as you're
comfortable with
without going to a level that puts you
in a
you know a position that really um
can be difficult for you right so it's
about
sort of understanding the the learning
part or
stepping up from what you learned from
the experience so i guess
um as i see this i want you to be
authentic i want to see your authentic
voice
um and be genuine about it who it is and
it should
it should speak to you but it it you
don't
have to feel like you have to your heart
has to bleed to get
you know something on the paper that's
going to be um
as you said helpful for us
i don't know how to share that that it's
it might be a really funny thing might
be something that's like
just really fun and important but it is
who
you are as a person right and so that i
feel like needs to be part does not have
to be this like
i found myself in the depths of some you
know
i don't know how to describe but it's
you know
how do you want to say that well i know
you've seen some of these essays too to
know
they come in all different shapes and
colors exactly and that heartfelt piece
like you said that's
you right talking about the things that
are important to you
that's that piece and then the
vulnerable
element i define that very broadly
being vulnerable means sharing can be
mean sharing something that's meaningful
for you
sometimes it's the things that you care
the most about
that's when you feel the most vulnerable
when you're putting it out there because
you don't know how the world may or
may not kind of react to it and so i
i would say don't always think
vulnerable as
um a place of uh fear
or um you know something you're hiding
but
vulnerable in sharing something that's
important to you and it that can be a
realization
from you know something more um personal
or it could be something that you you
talk about every day right it's that
feeling that you have connected to it
and then in terms of the intellectual
vitality and leadership
i don't think you need to strategize too
much about it this
that question in particular is more
about that self-reflection element
dean moss talks a lot about the body of
research let's say some of the most
successful leaders are the ones who lead
from a place of
mission and values and this is a way for
you to start
discovering those and letting us know
what are some of yours and what are some
of your motivations
[Music]
yeah it's a very good point um
you know i do think it is something i
used to share
when i would be on the road that if you
if you do your essay
well or if you really spend the time to
focus on it
it is likely something that's so core to
the
person that you are to you as a being
that it's a theme that resonates
throughout your life
and you know this individual uh
mentioned that they had heard from alums
and what i do hear from alums and
students
is that if um if done well it's the kind
of essay that if you read it
10 years post gsb the the
common denominator that theme
still resonates for the person that you
are right and it's the way that you make
decisions whether you know it or not
right
so when when faced with a decision
where you can go in two directions your
core is what makes you decide to go one
way or the other and those are the kind
of things that
um you know we hope to kind of hear
about whatever that might be for you
but yeah thing that that follows you
throughout your life
and is the essence of the person that
you are
yeah i've heard of alums who when faced
with
life choices maybe it's career maybe
life moves they've gone back to that
essay
so what was driving me what's the
resonates like
how am i gonna use that going forward
i'm not going to lie
i use it as i was writing cover letters
to be like
this is why i'm making this decision so
even beyond the application
you can use what you learned from this
question right it's like in almost every
decision you know for me
as i shared previously this um
value of curiosity and wanting to learn
and explore
like when faced with a decision i'm
always gonna try to go
with the like let's let's go out and see
that or
travel and understand and and and
just be more curious so that too is all
about
yeah yeah and a couple more questions
while we're still on this topic of
essays and then what we will get around
to a couple others from
different parts of the application um
there's a question here from chifang
about like how do you feel when you read
a great what matters most essay like
what what are some of the things that
make those stand out to you
um when i
i think it is when i feel like um at the
end of the
essay that i can say to myself okay i i
understand a little bit more who this
person is now
this is your application this by no
means um
demonstrates the person you are there's
so much more to you than what you can
put in the application
but it gives us a piece and a little bit
of a window
into um who you are as a person so
it that's a very vague way to answer but
for me
that's if if i come out of that knowing
huh okay now i get um because i think
the rest of the application really does
give you an opportunity to describe what
you've done
and the impact that you had things that
definitely
um you've had some control of and then
this
allows you to really elaborate on
you as a person so yeah
and i think that's how um
even if you're writing the same thing as
a ton of other people
when it's your interpretation of it and
its effect on you
and who you are like that immediately
sets it apart um so and
i don't think there's any topic that is
used too commonly because
the way that people interpret it is
always going to be different and so
celebrate the one that
you kind of are feeling embrace that one
um and i think sometimes the hardest
thing to tell people is
like giving them the power to do because
they're like oh now i can go in so many
directions
um and you know as you're leading
you're gonna be having to choose through
different opportunity sets different
choices
i think this is a fun way for you to
start
playing around in that area and
experimenting to find out
how you decide um so that's kind of this
like
unintended ripple effect of this
application process
which is also why i love are like our
questions are open but meaningful
yeah that's a great point i mean it it
you know leaders come in
in all shapes and sizes too and we're
not just admitting
someone with a you know specific
leadership style
people um have all kinds of leadership
styles and they can be
valuable in many different ways and so
yeah this is one of those things where
in the essay you have the liberty
to talk about um how you
how you make decisions how something
would you know how much you value a
particular thing and how that would
impact
uh the decisions that you make in your
life
yeah here's the question from ceca so
we've talked a lot about
kind of the essays the story how the
pieces connect like how should i balance
the detail of
resume versus you know impact you know
how do these
what types of information can i share
where that
give you those levels and bits of
evidence that really clarify that
picture
but what happens if you're not sure what
that
end goal is just yet um so
the question itself how can applicants
who don't know exactly what path they
want to take after business school but
rather want to use business school as an
opportunity to explore
and really understand the different
pathways and options like how do you
show that effectively in an
application without appearing confused
any examples of how previous applicants
have done this successfully
that's that's a great question um
i think i i don't want people to feel
like they have to have it all figured
out by any means in fact even though you
have the opportunity to share
some of your aspirations and career
goals and why stanford would be
a good fit we don't hold you to what you
write
and why stanford you know it's it's an
element that's important for us to hear
about what are the things that you're
you know ascribing to but um
we certainly and if you're part of the
stanford ethos
and community it is all about
um learning and keeping an open mind and
discovering new things
and having the support of the community
to help you think through that
so to some extent it should be a
two-year
exploration or journey for individuals
and it doesn't have to be you might come
in and be like i know i want to go from
x to y
and i'm pivoting or i'm staying in the
same career path
but i see the business um education as a
way to get me there
that's that's great too but i think
there's certainly some
liberties here for people to really use
the two years to
think about what's next for them we
don't often get an
opportunity to take a step back and
reflect and that's what the
mba program allows you to do you know if
you're locked
up in your career and have been doing
what you thought was appropriate this is
the time in your life where you can
really think about
what that next step looks like so um
i'm looking at it just to make sure um
how can you effectively without looking
confused
i think one thing that's important is if
you are
sharing something that's really let's
say for example
you have a passion for getting into
media
and um that is where you want to see
yourself go if there's
no evidence that you even dabbled in
that space
prior to coming to business school we
may question like oh why hasn't that
come up whether it was
you tried to get involved in some
organization when you were an undergrad
or even post grad
or that perhaps you had an externship
and you enabled yourself to do it in a
space where
you could kind of explore that um
it is helpful to see some element if
it's that if it is a passion of yours
uh that you want to pursue that there's
some evidence that you've explored a
little bit about that before
getting to the business school i don't
know that's my thought i might just
actually
question if i don't see enough that
shows me yeah sometimes that kind of
exploration might be in your essays too
right because not everybody might have
had the opportunity
to like dabble in the world of vc but
what is it about
venture capital that might speak to you
right so even if
it's in your what matters or somewhere
to let us know oh where does this
interest come into play how does this
fit in
so i actually think zika you
might be underestimating that how much
of a direction you might
already have i think exploration in and
of itself is
totally valid and uh like a really
relevant reason to go to business school
right stephanie just talked about it's
baked into the program pretty much like
i think like 70
75 of our students do at least one pivot
in some way shape or form
and there must be something you're
interested
in exploring maybe it's a field
maybe it is a role maybe it is
an impact that you're looking to make
so even as you're thinking about
exploration and the different options
there are going to be ways for you to
narrow that down into something that
feels bite-sized right the only people
or well the only person you need to
convince that this is a valid reason to
go to business school is you it's you
and so a couple ways for you to maybe
think through
all right um what could that be for me
and even if it's an open-ended like it's
open-ended in like that direction
um this feels weird plugging one of our
other events
but hearing your story one starting your
story i actually
like walk folks through a couple of
different exercises to help get those
juices
those creative juices going yeah um one
of the questions you might be able to
ask yourself is
if there was anything that you could do
no like preconceived notions of what
success was like
no fear of failure anything that you
want to do
what would it be do some brainstorming
do some free writing talk to people
about that
and you might be surprised at how much
focus you might already have or how much
kind of dimension and interest and me
you can add to that exploration element
so
definitely ways to do it and you
probably
already know more than you think you do
yeah
and what i do love that's so well said
well
i i i hope that people take that to
heart
um what i do love about the community
at the gsb is that if you are
doing that exploration you're going to
be surrounded by people who
instead of telling you why it can't be
done
or questioning they're really going to
be open up to tell me more about
that and how can i help support you and
really allowing you
to dig into that and and
and find out if it's something worth
pursuing or not as well
you know you might have a number of
different hypotheses
that you test during your two years yeah
so we have about seven minutes remaining
stephanie i think we can actually do
like a lightning round
of what's remaining so let's do that and
then we can close with any
final words of advice we have so um
would you view candidates with 14 years
how do you view
candidates with 14 years of work
experience
with someone who has a lot of experience
we're sharing um
we certainly value the perspective that
you could bring to the classroom
given the um experience you've had and
we
see that as a value add in the classroom
to be able to bring that perspective
yeah and it's not about how long you've
worked but what have you done during
that time
number of years of work experience age
those are not parts of our evaluation
process it's more about like
what footprints have you left behind
yeah yeah
all right next one any practical
suggestions on how to solve
when seems sound banal when put together
even though the individual
incidences are unique so how to tie
things together i'll take this one first
stephanie yeah
so even if plugging another event
yesterday sharing your story two
writing in the application we did a what
matters most to you and why
kind of thought exercise so we did a
quick version there
there is also already a posted a more
extended version
of that workshop that we did that i did
earlier in the year so definitely check
out our stanford gsb youtube channel
there are going to be
a bunch of videos there we're really
working on building out the number of
resources that you all can use
to help guide you through this process
we want everybody to know that
yes you can do this here are tools to
help you put your best foot forward
all right let's see um
understanding the parts of the
application is whole like the
process is holistic are there certain
parts that you feel applicants tend to
overlook
in terms of importance to the broader
evaluation process
uh no i don't think there's a general
theme i think
no yeah same no general theme
here's a question um nowadays it seems
that it has become fashion to mention
social impact and ngo work
uh that's the goal that's the goal
behind pursuing an mba
how do we as the admissions committee
distinguish true motivation behind
students
applying to the mba program okay so that
might not be so much of a lightning
round type question
yeah right um well
we hope that when you are sharing
whatever it is that's important to you
that it is
you know part of the application as i i
agree
that everything in here is um as
uh authentic as possible and so
no you do not have to fit a mold of
having
any desire for social impact necessarily
but what is important
is that you are authentically sharing
the values that are important to you
yeah if non-profit if ngo
if social impact is not what drives you
don't you don't have to i am not looking
for someone who wants to do that
necessarily
there's another question in the q a box
like do i have to want to change the
world
no that that's not at all something that
we're looking as like a necessity
this is about like how do you want to
almost like even think about changing
your life right going to business school
is going to help you look
at the world through different lenses so
changes can be small
and meaningful so but that's gonna
depend
on you and what your priorities and your
values are so
don't check listen to the chatter center
yourself we are look
and you're gonna be the most effective
and compelling when you're talking about
the things that you care about
yes and here's one more question and
maybe we can close on this
and then go into um advice
uh how do we view failure i think there
might be actually a couple different
questions here about
failure um let me make sure i'm getting
it properly
is it something you find it hard to
understand what the experience would
have been like like what do you say
how would we advise oh yeah and someone
else said
can applicants talk about their failures
positively so i think it's absolutely
you can talk about a failure i
you know um entrepreneurs will say
fail fail often to succeed sooner
or so there there's um value in
what you learn from the failure right so
i think
the failure itself can can feel like
just that
but it's actually what your outcome is
as a result of the failure like do you
use that as something that impedes you
going forward that you have the fear of
not being able to overcome
or has the failure itself taught you
to look at things in a different way and
overcome those challenges so uh
i i think failure is a natural
part of life um and actually is a
framework and fabric of who you are as a
person like
how you've grown and that's very
meaningful and so
take those as opportunities to convey
what you've learned
that's that's what i would say all right
and stephanie people have heard from me
enough throughout the week any final
parting words words of wisdom words of
encouragement that you can share with us
with everybody who shared time with us
today oh sure
i mean i think at a very high
level you know there's some
anxiety and um
fear or concern about oh my gosh should
i even apply
like the the you know acceptance rate is
so
low i couldn't possibly get in and i
would just say
that um a hundred percent sure where far
away of not getting in is not to apply
so the
most encouraging advice i can give to
everyone
is just to put your foot forward um
that that is going to give you the best
opportunity to
for us to learn about you and so i
encourage everyone on the line to
take that leap of faith to believe in
yourself
to put your best foot forward and apply
but thank you so much for sharing
this time with us stephanie thank you
for letting me
pick your brains chit chat about a
profession and job that we love
and being able to support folks through
it is just the most amazing feeling so
thank you thank you everybody out there
i hope to cross paths with you again
soon
until then stay safe
[Music]